instead of thinking like this is what I
want to be known for just talk about
what you're actually doing and you'll be
known for doing what you do trying to
say like I want to be known for this is
like trying to literally create a
fictitious version of yourself which you
will never sustain what you can be known
for on a sustainable basis is who you
actually are you'll be known for that
and so if you want to change what you're
known for change what you do and then
what you do will reflect in how other
people perceive you because that's the
only thing that's going to be
sustainable is talking about the things
that you will actually have credibility
on which is the evidence and proof of
the actions you have taken